und wer hammer der woche es gibt in köln
am rhein einfache mülltonnen wie diese
oder diese oder diese und es gibt solche
unglaublichen hightech-geräte den
sogenannten abfall hai mit solarbetrieb
der luxusschlitten unter dem
bundesdeutschen mülleimern die stadt
köln lässt sich das rund 8000 euro
kosten pro stück wohlgemerkt ein nobles
müll möbel dass der normale kölner
ziemlich beknackt findet geld genug hat
die sind kein problem ansonsten
übertreten teuer und ich muss sagen ich
bin schon echt übertrieben einmal einmal
vor allem ich denke die normalen tun hat
auch ich find das katastrophal ehrlich
gesagt ich finde dass zu viel
das steht in keinem verhältnis meiner
meinung nach der mülleimer im schicken
haifisch look designt hat als besonderes
gimmick dieses presswerk eingebaut damit
wird der müll zusammengedrückt
angetrieben wird das ganze durch diese
formschöne angebrachten solarzellen so
viel hightech hat natürlich seinen preis
11 stück für satte 88.000 euro
ein paar meter neben dem edel mülleimer
stehen die schlichten geschwister des
abfalls modell colonia für schlappe 350
euro das stück und die werden rege
genutzt
trotzdem hat sich die stadt die luxus
mülleimer gegönnt in köln will man von
geldverschwendung aber nichts wissen
und dann muss man sich eben überlegen
aber auch in die stadt gestaltet etwas
investiert am kölner rudolfplatz ist von
stadtgestaltung nicht viel zu sehen
man sieht den luxus mülleimer vor lauter
mülltonnen nicht aber auch das bringt
die verwaltung der rheinmetropole kaum
aus der ruhe
was das preis leistungsverhältnis angeht
haben die kölner schon jetzt ein
eindeutige meinung das ding ist einfach
zu teuer also die alten oder die anderen
mülltonnen erfüllen auch ihren zweck und
da muss nicht so weit her und das ist
totaler schwachsinn
ich denke mal es eine unnötige
anschaffung braucht man nicht wirklich
design hin oder her mit aufklebern
zugepackt und verträgt am ende ist das
schicke ding halt doch nur ein einfacher
mülleimer der aber einen haufen geld
kostet